[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PB censored Lu rubiales
sensationally quits in a world exclusive
interview with me for this program he
kiss goodbye to his job his reputation
but does he deserve to now kiss goodbye
to his Liberty also tonight Rory Stewart
is the rarest beast in British politics
he seems to unite right and left and
people actually rather like him he joins
me live to explain his extraordinary
State of Affairs and George was
governor of New York in his Darkest Hour
on 911 will ask what's happened to the
unity that that tragedy
[Music]
inspired live from the news building in
London this is pi Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored it's
the kiss that became a crisis the
infamous World Cup clinched between
Spain's football Chief LS rubiales and
Jenny hoso the star player and captain
of the Spanish team has divided opinion
across the globe to his critics rubiales
is a potent symbol of sexism of toxic
masculinity a man of authority
humiliating a woman and the scene as
provocative evocative of the power plays
they face every day to his supporters
though he's the man who's losing
everything over a single moment of OV
exuberance celebrating winning the World
Cup he's now carrying the can it appears
for bigger issues which are far beyond
his control that's what it's support to
say well tomorrow you can make your own
minds up you'll watch the full world
exclusive interview right here on talk
TV on Piers Morgan on Center at 8:00 pm
but 24 hours before it is we're already
making headlines across the planet and
this is why despite facing a wave of
attacks from colleagues celebrities even
as own prime minister Ru Alis
steadfastly refused to quit and insisted
he wasn't going to and then during my
interview to my surprise he said this
you've come under ferocious pressure for
three weeks now on you on your family
it's been very difficult for your
daughters they're young girls I can only
imagine as a father myself I have a
daughter who's around the age of one of
your girls incredibly difficult there
comes a point perhaps when the pressure
is just so relentless
Relentless that you do think about what
you should do with yourself and your
future many people think you should
resign as president what are you going
to
do I love so much my daughters um and
they they love me so so much I very
happy and I'm very proud of them very
very proud of them they are very near to
me about Maran Nation yes I'm going to
do you're going to Res yeah I'm going to
yes cuz I cannot continue my work for
for two or or three reasons first of all
I have a suspension and this suspension
is just starting and it's going to
continue I'm sure because if you can't
see how was
down it's going to
continue at the same time um I think
that the the
Federation I it's not a question about
if I can support or not this mediatic uh
tsunami it's about to know how it's
going to affect to the Royal Spanish
Football Federation and I love my
country and I love football and I don't
want damage for them well most people
around the world have only seen a short
clip of that kiss has been a rush to
judgment which in my opinion is
understandable it looks bad he shouldn't
have done it as we discovered and as
everybody will discover tomorrow it's a
complicated issue her Mero says the kiss
was not consensual but that wasn't what
she said in the immediate aftermath
she's now filed a criminal complaint for
sexual assault is that what that was
there's no denying it the rhetoric has
changed first and most who downplayed it
unexpected but no big deal and then
there was this video on the team bus
afterwards where she is clearly laughing
about it they all are they all start
chanting bezo bezo which is Spanish for
kiss kiss kiss and then prey prei which
is the president rubiales who then
appears rather sheepishly and he talks
about all this in my interview tomorrow
there's no sign is there with this video
that they all believe a terrible assault
has happened that's going to become a
global Scandal that will cost rubial is
his job that's not to mean that they may
not have reflected in the morning when
they saw the attention it was getting
overriding all that they'd achieved that
maybe they did then think actually this
was wrong and we've been violated I get
that and I can understand that could be
the case tomorrow's interview goes into
all of this rubial is is honest he's raw
he's passionate he's definitive about
some of these key questions and he
doesn't leave anything in the locker to
use a football turn it might change some
people's minds about him it did mine
what's clear is Rubi Alis say kiss
goodbye to his reputation his kiss
goodbye to what should have been the
crowning moment of his career this is
the greatest moment in Spanish football
history the men's team never won the
World Cup he's now kiss goodbye to his
job but should he kiss goodbye to his
Liberty too is it right that Rubi ales
is now facing a potential criminal
prosecution for that kiss that is a
debate that I can tell you from all the
conversations I've had with people in
the last few days a lot of L of people
have strong feelings either way well
tomorrow night right here Ruby ales
uncensored is a fascinating gripping
watch you won't want to miss that we
Jordan and discuss all this is daily
maale columnist Sarah V making her
uncensored debut long overdue I might
add especially given how uncensored you
are Miss Vine T ofy contributor Esther
kru I'm a socialist author Grace Blakey
do you like being called that of course
I do I'm a proud socialist you know that
you used to call me MOA Marxist which
was also quite F you don't sound you
just don't sound like you sound like the
poshest Socialist ever well yeah
obviously that's where Mo Marxist come I
know I get it I just socialism with
class exactly thank you Esther do you
want to be my my agent no yeah you don't
want that you don't want that you deal
with pear all the time let's get to more
serious matters ladies uh it's a great
panel for this because Sarah let's start
with you LS rubiales got carried away he
admits it right and he's very Frank
about this in our interview tomorrow and
we go over everything at length
but what followed is now being
categorized a sexual assault is that
what we all witnessed well I mean all I
can say is I've just seen the same clip
that everybody else has seen which is
him sort of overe excited grabbing her
and giving her a big smack on the lips
and I can't say that I didn't think
there was an iota of sexualness in that
sexualness sexuality sexiness whatever I
don't think it was sexual in any way it
just very overe excited and just wanted
to give her a big kiss on on the lips
cuz she'd done so brilliantly I mean
everybody was kissing everybody they
were kissing the trophy they were
kissing each other there was just a lot
of kissing going on it was quite kissy I
mean I thought it was a bit vulgar that
he grabbed his testicles in front of the
queen then I suppose and the queen
16-year-old and by the way we discussed
that and he's very you know he's very
open about how but again he feels about
that that may surprise people but but in
relation to Jenny HOSA right she is
having the best moment of her career but
for the next 3 weeks after that moment
of crowning Glory with them winning the
World Cup all that anyone has talked
about is her being grabbed by the
president of her football association
with both hands and snogged on the lips
now to put it in perspective If Prince
William who's the president of our
Football Association if when the Lioness
is a one the Euros a couple of years ago
if when that had happened William had
done that to the captain of the
lionesses I think all hell would have
broken Lo it could be an incentive also
for them to do really well and win if he
like Henry C
but obviously there's a cultural issue
here because if this was the men's team
and he as a male manager did that they
would have no problem because men
footballers I ask him that I asked him
about if it had been a men's team would
he have done the same thing and his
answer is really interesting so it is
complicated it's more nuan issue exactly
it's it's how it's how men it's it's
kind of brought into sexual Dynamics and
the mindfield that it's now is it's now
brought it to light but I think what
happened is this horrible sort of wormy
sort of me tooy thing has got to her
hasn't it because she she you saw from
the Bus video she didn't seem that upset
they were all sort of shouting know
what's going on in that cont look
clearly they clearly noticed the fact
that something go wrong because they
were chanting kiss kiss kiss they were
obviously like this is a bit weird it
was well she's looking in that video on
the this is on the bus after they've
left the stadium as world champions
they're all celebrating and drinking
she's looking at she a split screen on
her phone one is AA Casas the former
Spanish goalkeeper who had a similar
kiss with a woman TV reporter who turned
out to be his girlfriend or wife or
whatever and the other half is her being
kissed by rubiales and they're all
laughing and joking and chanting bezo
bezo which is kiss kiss kiss and then
prey prey right it doesn't on the face
of it look like they're all in Trauma
from his assault well I mean the point
isn't whether or not they've been
traumatized and we can throw around this
word trauma as though as though all
sexual assault is supposed to kind of
break a human being down to their very
core and they're like lying on the
ground crying that's not how sexual
assault happens you know you experience
it in the moment it's often shocking at
first at first you maybe don't even
process what's going on you're a bit
like oh someone's touched me in a
strange way but I don't want to make a
fuss about it because I'm on the tube or
I'm in a public space or I've just won
the Women's World Cup so you kind of go
along and then eventually someone's like
oh was that a bit strange and you're
like yeah maybe it was a bit weird when
that happened to me actually maybe I
would have liked that situation to have
taken place a bit differently and I
think that's clearly what's happened
here because ultimately I just quickly
want to say this before we we go on the
only thing that mattered after this
happened was that um he lost the support
of his team and he overtook all of the
publicity that had happened about this
positive event and that's what really
should have been the Crux he should have
stepped out well I don't think he should
have stepped down but I think for most
people watching that the fact that he
kissed all of them basically he didn't
single her out if he just apologized
this would have gone away and remember
how he reacted initially so on the night
and I played this to him in the
interview you know he he I reminded him
what he said but he calls everyone that
criticizes him dumb asses and blah he
really goes on the attack because I
think he genuinely is completely taken
back anyone would have a problem with it
right and I think that that's sincere I
think he just had no idea what he' done
I think watching it I was trying to
think this morning you know I was
talking to my wife about it like
somebody you don't know that well I mean
he does know them well so it's a
complicated thing but if somebody came
up and just kissed you on the lips who's
not your partner and not a a member of
your family or something and even then
depending on the family member is weird
right but I know people that have done
that to me at parties sometimes and
you're like what just done yeah why are
you kissing me on the lips it is it is
whether he meant any sexual intent is
one thing I don't I don't think he did
but but it still has a kind of sexual
element to it but I think I think it's
not the same as as someone coming up to
you randomly and just K kissing you on
the lips there was an event going on
everybody was celebr but he doesn't kiss
any of the others on the lips well I
don't know maybe he he just got so he
hugs them he kisses them on I think
you're right I think if he had just said
look I'm really sorry I was just in the
moment I really didn't mean anything he
had a match yeah he did because I think
he was just maybe his mother who went on
Hunger Strike which by the way my mother
I was with my mother at the weekend and
she affirmed in similar circumstances
she would also go really has she not had
to do that yet she has come I think
quite close she actually thought it was
a good idea for my next inevitable
scrape that she go on a mediate hunger
strip but also the other thing is is
there was no subterfuge to it I mean I I
mean I get what you say about sexual
assault but I tend to think that if
people have got malicious intentions
they don't do it they don't do it in
front an important point right whether
or not you know we can have this debate
whe was it sexual did he mean to do
something I don't think that he probably
meant to do something overtly sexual in
front of that massive crowd that he
thought was going to get but it's kind
of not the point the point is about
bodily autonomy it's about who is
allowed to tou Grace here's the question
should he have lost his job over it for
for the kiss never mind the Fallout but
the act mean I think the moment if he
had done the kiss and the players had
come out and said we were fine with this
it was a common thing that we do all the
time it's quite normal culturally it's
it's appropriate and it's fine whatever
then that would have been one thing the
fact is that that wasn't what happened
they came out eventually after you know
a period of reflection and said we're
not comfortable with this we're not okay
with this and ultimately the only thing
that matters is that he lost their
confidence and she did say to be fair to
them about them and to be fair to Jenny
HOSA there she is heard saying on the
night I didn't like it yeah right so I
don't think she's you know I think she's
probably wrestling with what this is
really happen her a special gift because
she scored the goal like I think that
was it like cuz we mention he didn't
kiss anyone else you want oh you are a
superstar particularly bril you know
what I mean let me ask you so Grace so
you think you should have lost his job I
think when he lost the confidence of the
team then he should have stepped down 81
members of the women's team and then the
men joined in they weren't going to play
again if he was sa pres the position
becomes rapidly untenable but should it
now be considered a crime she is now
pushing for him to be prosecuted she had
14 days to decide if she wanted to be
party to him being criminally prosecuted
and she took that option now that's
where I in this whole story I'm like
hang on hang on all right he loses his
job he was inappropriate and wrong he's
admitted that he's not hiding it we all
saw what happened right but is this
really a criminal act well look we had
the last time I was on the show when you
were away discussing this topic that was
a Spanish football journalist on who was
talking about the context for this and
this is really important because Spain
had recently passed a law outlining the
ways in which it was wasn't appropriate
to touch women to touch people uh in you
know in the context of sexual harassment
and this was seen as coming after the
passing of this law which said you're
not allowed to touch or kiss people in
these ways without their consent and if
you do then you know action can be taken
he just to be clear just to be clear and
he repats this in our interview he
believes that she did give consent for
the kiss now she says otherwise but he
is adamant that she did so there's a
obvious there's a he said she said right
and it may be impossible to get to the
bottom of well it's very difficult
because you're dealing with passionate
moments people don't tend to fill in
forms and triplicate asking for consent
when they when their blood is up and
when they're over give an example look
last week Paul gascoin met Prince
William randomly at a homeless event
down in Bournemouth where he lives and
he just went up and kissed Prince
William right I don't remember him
asking him if he could right so in other
words this kind of
interaction you know it did make me feel
like I'll be honest it made me feel a
bit uncomfortable watching what he was
doing and I think when he looks back on
it and the crotch grabbing in front of
the queen her 16-year-old daughter if no
thanks this is ridiculous way for a
president of a football association to
behave on the biggest stage in the world
particularly when your team just won
yeah so what are you doing not about you
um but I can buy into the idea he just
got completely carried away because they
won the World Cup I don't know if Aral
win the Premier League next season
season I don't know who I may jump up
and gu random but them in the I
sincerely hope none of you are in my
proximity footballers sort of
practically assault each other on
the you know you have to again like
learn to we we have to separate
intention from the outcome and
ultimately the law is done and that's
what I'm talking about right now it's
not done based on intention really other
than in certain cases
c not withstanding I think you make some
very good points unusually I have to say
um which I can almost buy into uh just
in your gut do you think he was trying
to make any kind of assault on her or
had any sexual motive for what he I
don't think this was about sex and
actually I don't think that a lot of
sexual assault cases are about sex we
know they're not they're often about
power I knew you they are about I mean
he was the president of the Football
Association there I mean there's no
doubt there is a power Dynamic he he's
the ultimate boss right exactly it's
about men thinking that they have some
sort of hold or charge or ownership over
another person's body um and sometimes
that has a sexual element to it
sometimes it doesn't but it's often just
an unthought Sarah Sarah does it in a in
a strange look it may be a conversation
women have to have by the way right with
each other about this because whenever
men poke their heads into this it's a
bit of ACH I do I've thought for a while
because me too was so extreme in the way
that sort of lacerated people and then
you felt like the pendulum swung back a
little bit and it was a conversation
women had to have amongst themselves
about what do we really think about this
my question would be about this is if we
perceive what he did knowing what we
know and knowing he did it all in the
full glare of the world's media here uh
if we perceive that to be a sexual crime
are we
diminishing what many people would see
are much more serious sexual crime I
think you are I think absolutely that is
definitely the case I think a lot of
these with me too there's as with all
these things there's always a real grain
of Truth it always comes from somewhere
it doesn't just happen out of nowhere
but what happens is people grab onto it
and then it becomes a crazy thing and
then even the tiniest thing is not allow
it does seem like it just gone too far I
think it's a bit like trans thing you
know there's a there's a really serious
issue there that's very important for a
very small number of people but then it
turns into a kind of massive R and
culture wars and it's a disaster I I
think that you know there's an element
in which there's there's a parallel in
the sense that most of the time the
boundary is fairly clear right in terms
of what is and isn't sexual assault and
yet we often see the situation where the
media picks up and goes with for a very
very long time a kind of an edge case a
fringe case a FR a case where you're
like oh was this or wasn't this and then
that's used to undermine the processes
and systems that are used to let's say
support trans people or prosecute sexual
assault and now we live in a country be
in mind where 99% of rape cases just
there's there's no justice for the
victims whatsoever and that's partly
because of the way our legal systems the
unusual the unusual the unusual thing
here is we all saw what happened yeah
right so there's nothing that we need
there's nothing more to see really I
mean there's a bit of interaction he
says from some slightly different angles
where he says that she lifted him up and
he says can I give you a PEC and she
says yes and maybe she didn't hear that
maybe she misunderstood him maybe it's
just a complete breakdown of
communication but certainly if you look
at the events afterwards in the dressing
room where they're all partying on the
bus where they're all partying I you
just don't get a sense I that anyone
thinks something really bad's gone down
here but in a way this is a microcosm of
what happens in a lot of these cases
which is that you know he doesn't think
he's done anything wrong he he's misread
the signals clearly she because she says
she's a victim we now have to say you
are a victim but I don't think she's a
victim maybe other people don't so then
so then we get to this awful thing where
everybody is like well you can't say
she's not a victim because she is a
victim because she says she's a victim
but you say but I see I saw what
happened commit sexual assault on hold
talking of victims I do want to just
take a bit of time out for Mr it's been
a great debate by the way um just to
mention my heart goes out to this guy
he's a guy called Martin Dorney he's a a
GB news uh Pres presenter um it's a
another Network apparently I don't watch
it um he's a former brexit party MEP and
he recently tweeted a few months ago
some thoughts about me in relation to
coid uh I'd said that once the science
changed about coid and it was revealed
that the vaccine didn't stop me
transmitting the virus I changed my view
about punishing people who wouldn't have
it by removing some of their rights and
I look back and all had a rethink about
some of it so I think it's the right way
to approach things Democratic Society
not always right about everything much
as I tend to have a very high percentage
um but he said this Morgan blindly
regurgitated propaganda and utterly
failed as a journalist we can imagine
how hurt I was to read this um to be
called a journalistic failure by Martin
dorany but the great thing is he had a
chance uh the weekend to show me what
journalism really is because Martin
happened to be in the GB news Hot Seat
uh when we had the terror sub uh suspect
was caught I think and and he had the
job of just bringing the very simple
task because the easiest thing in this
job is breaking news he just basically
people talk in your ear and you re beat
it on there and you just keep calm and
you just do your thing this is what
Martin who is my journalistic tutor this
is what he did we're going straight to
me this is breaking news it's fast
happening because as we just said um
with with the a the teraman this all
gone
wrong here chip Chapman and we have him
coming up soon on the arrest of the
terror suspect he he escaped from ons
withth prison and he's been apprehended
it's all coming up in GB news we got our
first guest here it is Police have
Escape of Arrested prisoner Daniel khif
beg your pardon we're getting the or in
the right place this story is Just
Happening joining me now for the latest
is GS home security editor Mark White
are you there
Mark it's Chip Chapman we have chip
Chapman Army um for the Army anger
former head of counterterrorism Major
General chip Chapman well I can quite I
can quite see why Martin views himself
as a a journalistic scholar uh who else
could bring teraman into a subject like
that um a brilliant masterclass I think
in journalism uh and how to cover
breaking news from Martin do I will try
better Martin I you're be right I am a
failure um and I will try but I will
watch that video actually I will watch
that video every day probably for the
rest of my Natural Life as a template in
how to cover breaking news because you
my friend you are the master so thank
you thank you to my Pat don't leave us
for long next time it was pure dro the
dead donkey wasn't it yes it was you
literally if you were doing a par it
better if you were doing a parody of
somebody cocking up breaking news old
ders he would he would win the parody of
the Year award uh thank you to my
tomorrow night you going to watch it the
rubial yeah definitely it is very
interesting and and I think it's a
really interesting debate about all
these issues it's kind of a debate of
our times but thank you Pat good to see
you all uncensor next Rory Stewart
Sensational new Memoir is making
headlines for exposing the inner omn
shambolic workings of Westminster and
whiteall join me after the break and
it'll be live here in the
[Music]
studio
[Applause]
[Music]
under the previous employment section of
his CV my next guest is Soldier Diplomat
charity CEO award-winning travel rides
at Harvard professor and most recently
Britain's top podcaster M his role as
politician at the subject of his new
book Politics on the edge which records
in full uncensored fashion the complete
Omni shambles at the heart of our
British political system well make
making his uncensored debut I am
genuinely delighted to have probably the
most liked politician in Britain but the
bar is low Rory J the bar is
very let's start with that because
you've got out of politics many people
lot of my family um wish you hadn't wish
you were right in the front line of the
thing why did you eventually just say
I'm just done with this I I I I met the
end with Boris Johnson I mean that that
was the end for me and I i' you know put
in a good nine years had been a cabinet
St i' um I liked Theresa May thought she
was trying to do the right thing but I
really thought that Boris Johnson was a
dangerous thing I thought he was a
shambolic clown I thought he was going
to be very damaging for our
Constitution and and he was and and I
felt he was yeah I mean that's exactly
how he turned out to be I mean you were
very preent in your assessment of him
which led you to leave I guess the
problem is if people like you don't want
to stay in our system it's never going
to improve it's a difficult balance
doesn't it P really difficult balance
you you put up with a lot you work out
how much you can put up with and at some
point you have to be like enough's
enough you I mean you you're quite
direct about some of our former leaders
of Theresa May she had some of a
Monarch's stiff Authority not
necessarily a negative I guess David
Cameron later in cabal you Ry came
across like a host at a pheasant shoot
rented only for the day courtesy
presiding were there any particular
desire to know about the detail of the
soil on which he was standing or about
the profession
whose job it was was to drive the game I
mean a real picture of superficiality
there from that prime minister yeah I I
I thought that um when I came in that
one of the things that struck me first
and it's probably something you see a
lot the public sees a lot is
fundamentally a lack of
seriousness uh it really has become like
a massive campaigning Communications
game and there isn't any time really to
talk about policy you would have thought
that secretly they might take their
masks off and they get around the
cabinet table and they're like okay
enough with going out to the media what
do we really think about this but it
happens so rarely I mean the worst by
miles of all your stories it might be
the worst thing I've read in a long time
Liz truss and you write this back in
London Liz truss asked me how my weekend
had been I explained that my father had
died she paused for a moment nodded and
ask when my 25-year environment plan
would be ready I I read that and I
thought I can't believe I'm reading that
and then I thought actually Yes actually
I can believe I'm reading that because
lith trust always exuded an air to me of
somebody who probably would behave like
that yeah without a shred of decency or
basic Humanity no no I I mean I I think
she's um she she's a very unique human
being I I had a I worked for list truss
I worked for pretty Patel I worked for
Boris Johnson and it was a real
education but that moment yeah well that
was very sad for me I mean obviously I
love my father deeply and I was um but I
think that's more that's more that's
more awkwardness I think she's somebody
who that's not awkward that's just a
total lack of basic humanity and maners
is I think she's somebody who doesn't
relate very easily to other people I
maybe that's maybe I'm psychologizing
too much but yeah richy soon that you
call Mack aell what why do you call him
that I think probably because I sensed I
I used to sit next to him the library in
the com big kind of wooden library and
he was my library partner so I was quite
fond of him um but I didn't quite get
why he'd suddenly gone hard for brexit
and particularly even when I got around
that I I understand many of my friends
voted brexit I couldn't get round him
getting in behind Boris Johnson so hard
because he'd seemed to me quite a sort
of thoughtful serious he seems a kind of
serious guy you're talking about yeah
but I but I agree if I was if I was
talking to him which I do occasionally
the brexit thing I didn't understand why
he would be that supportive and I agree
about Boris I guess I guess if Boris is
the lead
you either fall in behind or you do what
you did and just get out of it right but
he he fell in behind pretty quickly I
the reason I found it difficult is that
it was the MPS who made it possible for
Boris because if you remember in this
leadership contest you needed the MPS to
vote from him first and basically there
were a whole middle group of MPS and
you'd say to them we know him very well
we've worked with him I'd work with him
in the foreign office we know that he
doesn't really pay attention we know
he's pretty careless about a lot of
stuff you don't really think he'd be a
good prime minister do you and they'd
say no they say why are you supporting
him and they'd say because he's going to
win but hasn't politics always been full
of charlatans and unprincipled people
and if we accept that that's a bitter
reality not all I've met some very
decent people in politics actually um
but it's not entirely surprising that
people like Boris Johnson Donald Trump
and others in a televisual age the ones
who can crack a joke and make people
laugh who have a little bit less of the
robot about them people thought TOA May
was robotic it's not entirely surprising
that they rise to the top and have a
constituent that will support that no
it's not surprising politics always had
charlatans and bluffers and I think we
people like me from the kind of Center
ground of politics have a lot to answer
for think 2008 financial crisis showed
that we'd mismanaged the economy I think
Iraq and Afghanistan were horrible
foreign policy humiliations and so I
think people like Trump or Johnson are
resp responding to a genuine public
anger these guys screwed up they didn't
know what they were doing the problem is
what people are choosing to do is throw
them like a h grated the system but I
mean in Trump's case it's effective he
just tears up any rules that have gone
before he doesn't care and he has a
constituent audience that don't really
care what he does or what he says yeah I
I think it's true for both of them but I
I think that to counter that there's
always going to be people like Donald
Trump or Boris Johnson around what's
lacking is the seriousness and the kind
of middle ranks of politics and that's
why I think the system feels so broken
what do we do about it how do we fix it
I think we have to decentralize we have
to take power out of Westminster I'm
very excited by you know the mayor of
Manchester mayor of West Midlands and M
Street and I think we got to get out of
this Victorian idea that a bunch of
amateurs sitting in Parliament are going
to be able to micromanage the country
you were a tutor to Prince William and
Prince
Harry so what do you feel about what's
happening with those two so I I don't
talk about it's the one thing I know
that's why I've asked you it's the one
thing the show's called uncensored Rory
here and start self censoring that
matter with you man I think if I'm
teaching them I I owe just on a human
level owe them confidenti I like them
both very much they were lovely boys do
you feel sad about what's happened they
they now hate each other so much they
don't even talk to each other definitely
feel sad yeah that far is he going to go
far as not going to go who was who was
the brighter as far as I go you were the
tutor I'm going to go that's not my job
from a military perspective when I watch
Harry doing his evictor games thing I
think good on you when I think about his
service to his country I think good on
him yeah you know my brother-in-law
taught them both at Santos actually um
and thought they were both good soldiers
um when I see him the other half of him
running around the world trashing his
family and the monchy and everything I
can't stand it yeah I I I I sympathize a
lot of what you're saying I'm a big
supporter of the king I'm a big
supporter of the Prince of Wales I'm
very proud of the Royal Family and I
think that's very very sad should he
stick to stuff like the invictor games
and just shut up trashing the Royals I'm
staying out of this one p you
effectively just just said you agree I
know I agree with a lot of things he
said as his former
tutor dragging me too deep you'll sell
some books here Rory come on bit of bit
of uncensored honesty let's take a break
I want to talk to you after the break
it's 911 anniversary today and I want to
ask where you were when it happened but
also it it prompted wanted you to go on
this extraordinary 2year walk through
Afghanistan and other countries I want
to know why you did that what you
learned what we should all learn perhaps
from that period That's start for the
[Music]
break good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City King pi and
King h there's only room for one king
man you know what I'm saying he's moed
your weight Trump yeah look at him fail
stop working just cuz they skin folk
don't mean they're kin folk do you
believe you can win this war making me
cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betrayed keep it
awardwinning Lucy Ley will die behind
bars and a senior Doctor Who first
raised concerns about Ley once NHS
manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what s
years down the line I mean it's it's
completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty ktie that would make her a
better princess of wealth gay Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time oh he wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7:30 p.m. the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes lab 29
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application for him and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
Rest their
souls Let It
Roll y yes if we stop producing oil the
knock on effect is far larger than just
CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me off chart
this some of them they're easily l
you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you and we're
just asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth you don't drink never taken
drug you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned if it's on your mind it's on
talk TV is about you and your opinions
if you're thinking about it we're
talking about
it it's all about me I'm a
[Music]
joke this is talk
TV everybody in prison says they're
innocent
this is the first time people have ever
heard you
speak you here to expose the truth they
came with an open
mind we want to be fair and openminded
that's all I really
want now is the time to be completely
honest you're the person I've wanted to
talk to about these
issues why should people watching this
believe
you you're every family's worst
nightmare here should turn in this
interview into what it's not
it executed them I'm really sorry B
yeah why did you do it I'm sitting my
job to answer your questions your job to
answer mine if it wasn't you who did
it now we can judge for ourselves to get
to the truth how can I believe you I
don't care if you do it now the killer
interview with Piers Morgan streaming
Tuesday on Fox
[Music]
Nation welcome back to PG that's my new
uh eight-part crime documentary series
which airs in America on Fox Nation uh
interesting stories some very dangerous
people sitting well unnervingly close to
me at times uh but well worth watching
if you're in the states I'm back with
Rory Stewart here the uniquely popular
and liked British political figure um
leis rubiales I wanted to ask you about
that because it's everyone's talking
about this this guy and you've managed
to get an interview with him yes so I've
got a big interview with him ering
tomorrow night we got the first
interview and it was very interesting he
was very open very Frank about it he
said look I was an idiot I shouldn't
have done it what do you feel though
about him potentially facing a criminal
prosecution now for the
kiss um I actually quite sympathize with
a lady at the end there who was saying
that um it's quite possible that the
woman at the time might not really have
felt very much but that afterwards you
can feel very very dis I mean look I
it's very difficult to judge Spain
different mores different cultures but
I think you got to be pretty careful
about that kind of thing yeah it's an
interesting sign of the time that it's
created such a furor actually 911 it's
the
202nd anniversary uh today of 9911 I
remember where I was I was lying on a
sofa recovering from back surgery and
was supposed to be lying there for three
weeks it was about eight days in I got a
call from a Daily Mirror Newsroom I was
the editor I got straight in my car and
drove to Canary wolf not even thinking
that that might be a Target itself it
was the most extraordinary day of my
career and obviously horrendous in so
many ways where were you when it
happened I was uh walking across ASA i'
been walking for about a year and a bit
and I didn't understand what had
happened I was I met a guy sort of
probably couple of days after 911 and he
started trying to explain to me in
Nepali he said you know it's this Tower
in America and this plane hided and
night thought this guy was crazy I
literally you had you had no awareness
of it at all processing these words but
I was like it's like he's telling me
there's been some sci-fi attack in New
York so it wasn't until the 18th of
September I was arrested and accused of
being an Al-Qaeda activist up on the uh
Tibetan Nepali you are the least likely
Al-Qaeda activist I probably ever met so
this is what I said I said to the
policeman I said I'm not very likely
alqaeda and he said that's exactly why I
think you are it was like inspector clo
all things the walk that you were on and
you carried on for a long time you did
two years in the end it's an
extraordinary thing to do to Just Walk
and Walk and Walk and Walk what was the
motivation for that I had been a briefly
a British soldier then I was a diplomat
and I felt that I was locked behind
these Embassy walls and we were getting
involved in these other countries we had
no idea what was happening so I walked
across Afghanistan just after 911 I
walked uh through the winter of December
January February March just the Taliban
government fell and it was changed my
life changed me as a politician changed
me as a diplomat because I saw the gap
between these Villages I was in where
women had not been more than two hours
walk from their Village in their lives
where I could see drugs being traded
people with guns and then I turn up in
Afghanistan in Kabul and I hear the
British government the American
government saying every Afghan wants a
gender sensitive multiethnic centralized
State based on Democracy human rights
and rule of law and I thought I can't
even translate that into language they
understand
so my life was changed I mean 911 was a
horrible event but it Define the next 10
years of my life I was in Afghanistan I
was in Iraq was working to advise the US
government and I was trying to stand up
against what I saw is The Madness of how
people were responding when you see
what's going on in Afghanistan now with
the Taliban just obviously taking back
full control and oppressing women again
in their Millions terrible
poverty what is the answer I mean Tobias
Ela got into hot water for was a very
clumsy video he put out but the central
message we should start engaging again
with the Taliban did you have some
sympathy with that I did have sympathy
with that because the truth is that when
we sanction people at the Taliban we
don't change their behavior they're not
trying to go shopping in haret all you
end up doing is punishing the Afghan
people these are some of the poorest
people in the world very very difficult
to feed themselves over the winter
people selling their own organs to feed
themselves so I think we can find ways
of providing assistance the Afghans
without going through the government and
sanctioning the government just makes
the area poorer and more unstable and
when you look at Ukraine there's a
growing sentiment amongst some
Republicans to my surprise in America
that America should yank the support
spend it at home not on this latest
foreign conflict what's your view of of
what's happening there I mean do you
think Ukraine can win is it incumbent on
the west to ensure they can win how far
do we get involved I fear that Ukraine
is getting like the Iran Iraq war which
dragged on for eight years I think we're
underestimating Russia depth and
strength and the nationalistic sentiment
I think it's going to be very difficult
for Ukraine to break through the front
lines and even if they do I don't think
Russia is going away and I think the
threat to Putin isn't from the left it's
from the right you tell a story in your
book of how as an MP you thought about
killing yourself of a story of your
constituent trousers that went viral he
gave an interview where he said some of
the farmers the more remote parts of
constituency hold their trousers up with
twine he got picked up and he's accused
of being a POS you are of being a posh
Tory who thinks his voters are country
bumpkins yeah it's it's it's a it's a
strange thing looking back at it over 12
years I can see now that I was
completely
overreacting what I'm trying to be
honest about I suppose is as a new MP
coming in you
feel a very special relationship with
your constituents I was very proud of
Cumbria I was very proud of the work I
was doing I said a stupid thing to a
journalist and suddenly it looks like
I'm slagging off my own constituents and
I really felt everything had ended I
sort of felt it's extraordinary that you
would feel it so deeply mean how close
did you come to to acting on that
impulse um it's the only time in my life
I have felt like that I was I was
walking down the street and I saw a lamp
post and I thought maybe I should hang
myself as lamp post are you serious
yeah yeah it was it was very it's the
only time in my life but it was and I
think it shows something because you
felt you'd broken that Bond of trust
with the constituent probably I you know
I I think a lot of this is is about uh
the way that you exaggerate
relationships with people but I felt
that an MP with their
constituents is like a a priest or a
doctor you have a very special
relationship and that if you break it
you're you're breaking your vocation you
know I me I read it it was a startling
thing to read I have to say though in
the context of the point you're trying
to make I do want more politicians to
feel that seriousness about that Bond of
trust with the electorate because if you
don't have that
if you treat the electorate with the
kind of casual triviality that Boris
Johnson did or the recklessness that Liz
trust did or whatever I think if you do
that democracy slowly starts to die and
if we don't have a strong democracy in
this country I don't know what we're
left with thank you and I think what I'm
trying to do in the book in in in
politics on the edge is to show yes a
bit of humor but above all to
demonstrate that there is a big big
problem that this is no way to run a
government and that we need to reform we
need to reform our electoral system we
need to reform ministers going in and
out every couple of months out of their
jobs to have a serious country and you
know what else we need Rory we need you
back in the game you may not want to do
it but actually I think you
should thank you you going to uh I think
about just made you think about it I
think no it has made me think about it
more and it's made me think that
probably the way back in maybe is more
local as I say I'm very envious of
Mayors I thought about running to be an
independent for mayor of London and
that's so something I think about a lot
Politics on the edge it's a fascinating
it's actually a pretty scary book
actually because you lift the lid off
what we all fear is lying underneath in
our parliamentary system and it's got to
evolve and it's got to change we need
more people with your intellect and
seriousness I think than we currently
have and that would help enormously Rory
St thank you and being uncensored well
says next is George he was a
governor of New York City during 911
I'll be asking him if today's divided
America betrays the Legacy of the people
who died that
[Music]
day
[Applause]
[Music]
e
coming up on the talk the Parliamentary
researcher accused of being a Chinese
spy rejects the claims and Terror
suspect Daniel khif may have used bed
sheets in his escape from wesworth
prison and the BBC is slammed as R
remainers hijack the last night of the
proms with EU Flags that's all coming up
at
[Music]
9: well the events of 9/11 brought the
us together like never before in modern
history was a tragedy that seemed to
unite politicians of both parties as
well as people from every part of the
country in a spirit of patriotism and
togetherness today however exactly 22
years since that fateful day the nation
remains arguably more divided than ever
so what happened and can the disuniting
of the United States be reversed we here
to discuss this is a man who was
governor of New York on September 11th
2001 George Governor great to have
you on the program especially today
thank you Piers nice being on with you
it must bring back so many evocative
memories for you that awful
day H awful day is the right word you
know when I go down the ground zero as I
approach it you just just have this
tremendous sense of loss you know the
the friends and people you worked with
the firefighters who died that day and
and we'll never we'll never be able to
bring them back and uh it's just uh
really a sad day in that sense but also
uh you can't help but appreciate the the
courage how New Yorkers and Americans
responded that day and the weeks and
months therea and when I go down there
as well I see the the life the
excitement the vibrancy of lower
Manhattan and that makes me proud that
for all the horror we've come back
stronger than ever in lower Manhattan
that is indisputable true I'm in
Manhattan a lot and it's been remarkable
to see how that City but it doesn't
surprise me New York's an incredible
City with Incredible people it has that
Spirit about it reminded me of London
after the Blitz and so on in World War
II but what's happened to the unity that
when America came together after 911 I'd
never seen anything quite like that I
remember George Bush I think we got a a
clip of George W bush the president
throwing the first pitch at the Yankee
Stadium and this was what
happened so this was the president of
the time George W bush uh being
unanimously cheered by a roaring Yankee
Stadium and Governor when you see that
that couldn't happen anymore things are
so toxic now so tribal so partisan that
whoever's president no one's going to
get that kind of response and the latest
poll shows 65% of Americans believe
America's never been so divided do you
feel that and if so what is the
answer appears absolutely I feel that
and that's one of that's the second
tragedy of September 11th one was who we
lost that day but the second is how a
country that was the most unified in my
lifetime is now the most divided I've
ever seen in my lifetime and I I think I
don't mean to be overly simplistic but
it comes down to leadership you need to
have a leader leaders who look to
inspire the people with a common Destiny
going forward and instead uh for years
now we've had just partisan division
aimed at my party winning more than the
other party and instead of bringing us
together from the top down it's been
about divide for political benefit and I
think that is a tragedy that uh has hurt
this country but I don't think it's
irreversible you know the spirit of the
American people is still there the
belief in the future of this country is
still there we just need the Right
leader I me you talk about the Right
leader you know President Biden is not
in America on 911 he's in Alaska on his
way back from his foreign travels I've
Just Seen reports that Ronda santis the
governor of Florida is at Ground Zero
that carela Harris is there but not the
president of the United States does that
surpris
you um it's disappointing more than
surprising and uh you know I I I don't
think President Biden wants to have
anything to do with September 11th you
know uh first of all it resulted in the
Afghanistan War uh and how that ended
under Biden's watch was a catastrophe
that uh we're going to be paying for for
years to come and uh the terrorists uh
came to America and now we have an open
border and and we know know that
hundreds of people on the terror watch
list have crossed the southern border
and I fear that because of this absence
of leadership something will happen
again so it's disappointing Biden was
there it doesn't surprise me I think he
wants to distance himself from this as
much as possible but he can't he's the
president of the United States we need
him as a leader a lot of people around
the world are looking at the next
American election are thinking is it
really going to be Biden Trump again is
that the best America can offer at one
guy's got near 100 charges that he's
facing other one barely looks like he
knows what day it is um do you share
that sort of disqui that this is the
best of the best in
America absolutely I share that this
quiet but I'm an outlier purs in the
sense that I don't think either one of
them's going to be the nominee I think
uh the Democratic Leadership that helped
Biden basically put Biden in in 2020
because they knew Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren and KLA Harris were all
losers and they R behind Biden that
sorry we run out of time I'd love to get
you back CU I'm really enjoying this
conversation please come back another
time it's been great having you on
sensed I appreciate
it thank
you good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City King pi and
King Q I think there's only room for one
king man you know he's mocked your
weight Trump yeah look at him fail not
working just cuz they're skin f F don't
mean they're kin folk do you believe you
can win this war is making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award
winning Lucy Ley will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about Ley once NHS manages to
be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what 7 years down the
line I mean it's it's completely
ludicrous we need accountability we need
performance in all walks of life if this
nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wealth gay Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time oh he wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7:30 p.m. the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes lab
29 the
can did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application for and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God rest your
souls
[Music]
let it
roll